welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka spoils and Berg
and whilst El Camino does a brilliant
job of wrapping up the story of Jesse
Pinkman the two-hour film still leaves
one huge lingering question at the end
this question is what was in the letter
in an interview with IGN Aaron Paul who
plays Jesse in the film answered some
questions and throughout this video will
be playing the clip of what he said what
it could have meant and why it was cut
now there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had a chance to watch
alchemy know yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
letter
okay so El Camino ends with Jesse
Pinkman escaping to Alaska to start a
new life jesse has very little holding
him back with pretty much everyone other
than skinny Pete and Badger being there
for him however there was one more
person that he left behind and that is
Brock until oh the son of his girlfriend
Andrea who was sadly killed in order to
keep Jesse in line whilst we never
learned what is in the letter that Jesse
sends to Brock when speaking to IGN
Aaron Paul said the following on its
contents that's actually the very first
thing that Vince wrote when he wrote
this script it was originally in the
script but then it was cut out before we
started rolling it's just such a
beautifully honest heart-wrenching sort
of love letter to Andrea and to Brock a
confession
in many ways it's hard it was very hard
to read and you know hopefully knock on
wood Vince will allow me to sort of lis
release it to the world one day I fought
very hard to have it still in this film
but he wanted to leave it to mystery
okay so it sounds like it was pretty
deep and it's interesting that Paul says
that it was also in some ways addressed
to Andrea which will perhaps give some
closure to Brock who probably still has
no idea why his mother was murdered as
Todd and Jack's gang were never arrested
for the crime this may mean that jessie
is still really hung up on Henry as well
and we do see that he is heavily haunted
by his past during the special even
though Andrea doesn't make an appearance
I think whilst we as audience members
didn't get closure on it at least Brock
did and the apology sounds really
emotional now we also know that the
letter was originally in the film and
there have also been official statements
that it was in a voiceover at the end
though we don't know why it was cut I
would imagine because letters like that
at the end of films are often quite
cliche and it was also quite a private
thing that's purely for the characters
we can also draw our own conclusions
over what was said rather than to have
it definitively put across as it may
have just been quite straightforward and
not really needed addressing we did get
a flashback with Jane which I think
works better than the voiceover as it
addresses that Jessie is moving on to a
new life rather than being hung up on
the past he was left behind with his
letter to Brock being his final goodbyes
to his previous life I can't imagine
that the letter will be posted on social
media at some point once people have had
a chance to watch the film and I'll
update the pinned comment on this video
once that's out so keep an eye out also
just want to say a huge rest and peace
to Robert Forster who sadly passed away
yesterday those who are fans of Breaking
Bad and El Camino will know that he
played the vacuum repair guy in the
series and film and Forster was a
fantastic actor that really brought a
charm maturity and sophistication to
everything that he worked
you could tell that the guy had a kind
heart and he will be a huge loss so yeah
here's the you robber now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the letter
and if you hope that we get to read it
one day or if you think it's better off
being left and said comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full spoiler breakdown
of El Camino which you'll be linked at
the end I'll go over everything that you
need to know about the special and give
my review on it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me on Twitter
then make sure you follow me at
definition YT and if you want to join my
discord that make sure you click on the
link in the description below we've got
an awesome community made up of people
just like you and it's the best way to
stay up to date with the channel also
just wanna let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
letter in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue row be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]